[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
mietri Serien schönen guten Abend alles
Wichtige vom Sport später wieder mit
Norbert Lehmann ja mit Fußball
Bundesliga und dem Sieg der Mainzer
gegen die Bayern das haben wir heute
unter anderem für Sie vorbereitet
vierte Runde nach dem schlichter Spruch
haben die Tarifparteien im öffentlichen
Dienst ihre Verhandlungen wieder
aufgenommen
mögliche Evakuierung aus dem Sudan der
Krisenstab der Bundesregierung berät
über die Rettung deutscher Staatsbürger
und spektakuläre Aussicht der Skywalk
auf Rügen ermöglicht einen einmaligen
Blick auf Deutschlands bekanntesten
Kreidefelsen
[Musik]
Lösung dringend gesucht heute bei der
inzwischen vierten Verhandlungsrunde im
Tarifkonflikt des öffentlichen Dienstes
es geht um das Einkommen von zweieinhalb
Millionen Beschäftigten von Bund und
Kommunen Verdi und Beamtenbund hatte die
letzte Verhandlungsrunde für gescheitert
erklärt woraufhin die Schlichtung
aufgerufen wurde und das liegt jetzt auf
dem Tisch ab Juni dieses Jahres soll
schrittweise bis Februar 2024 ein
Inflationsausgleich von insgesamt 3000 €
gezahlt werden zum ersten März 2024 gibt
es erst einmal für jeden 200 € mehr und
dann ein Plus von 5,5 % insgesamt
mindestens 340 €. wie die Chancen stehen
dass die Tarifparteien dem Folgen Katrin
Lindner und Jan Meyer
Gewerkschaftsmitglieder demonstrieren
vor dem Verhandlungsort in Potsdam nicht
nur die Inflation macht den rund 2,5
Millionen Beschäftigten des öffentlichen
Dienstes von Bund und Kommunen zu
schaffen unsere unintelligible nicht
Stellen bekommen wir nicht besetzt weil
sie woanders um einfach auch mehr
bekommen ich arbeite in der Kita und
das der Personalmangel und der
fachkraftmangel ist einfach so enorm und
dann muss einfach müssen einfach bessere
Bedingungen geschaffen werden müssen
ständig Überstunden machen und die Teams
werden immer weiter runter reduziert und
das ist das Problem bei dem beschäftigt
zeigen Sie bitte liebe verhandlungsspiel
auf der Arbeitgeberseite dass die junge
Menschen schätzen dass sie die
Kolleginnen in ihrem in ihrem
öffentlichen Dienst schätzen die
schlichtungsempfehlung bedeutet allein
für die Kommunen einen Mehraufwand von
17 Milliarden Euro dennoch zeigten sich
die Arbeitgeber entschlossen zu einer
Einigung zu kommen die Zeiten sind sehr
schwierig deswegen müssen wir sie auch
angemessen alimentieren ich glaube das
wird uns auch heute gelingen ich bin
jedenfalls sehr zuversichtlich der
Bergische zeigte sich zufrieden dass die
Schlichter zweistellige Lohnerhöhungen
für Geringverdiener vorschlagen doch er
will auch Verbesserungen für
Teilzeitbeschäftigte und azu bis aber
wir sind entschlossen und gehen
konstruktiv in diese Gespräche hinein
und hoffen dass auf der Grundlage der
schlichtungsempfehligung Empfehlung eine
Verständigung möglich ist ob es heute am
Verhandlungstisch zu einer Einigung
kommt ist noch offen
ja und Katrin Lindner beobachtete das
Ganze für uns in Potsdam Katrin wonach
sieht es denn aktuell aus
ja draußen vom Verhandlungsort herrscht
aller schönste Sommerwetter doch davon
haben die Verhandlungspartner rein gar
nichts seit sieben Stunden wird hier
hart verhandelt und noch ist niemand
rausgekommen mit einem Ergebnis
Grundlage für die Verhandlungen ist der
Schlichter Spruch und er würde allein
die Kommunen 17 Milliarden Euro kosten
von ihrer Seite heißt es ein noch nie da
gewesener Betrag und das muss man wissen
vor dem Hintergrund
finanzschwache Kommunen nicht nur im
Osten sondern auch im Westen wie zum
Beispiel im Saarland oder Gelsenkirchen
von Seiten der Gewerkschaften heißt es
der Schlichter Spruch hat noch nicht
alle Themen berücksichtigt es gibt noch
viele kleinteilige Themen dienen am
Herzen liegen und die sie besprechen
müssen das kostet nicht nur Geld das
kostet auch eine Menge Zeit kommt es
nicht zu einer Einigung kommt das zu
einem Abbruch dann werden die
Gewerkschaften die Urabstimmung
einberufen und dann ein unbefristete
Streiks sieht also noch nach einem
langen Abend aus danke nach Potsdam
Katrin und am Montag sind wieder
Fluggäste von einem Warnstreik betroffen
und zwar alle die vom
Hauptstadtflughafen BER starten wollen
es wird keine Abflüge an diesem Tag
geben teilte der Betreiber mit weil das
luft- und Sicherheitspersonal ganztägig
streikt aufgerufen dazu hat die
Gewerkschaft Verdi die unter anderem
höhere Zuschläge für Wochenend und
feiertagsarbeit fordert
seit einer Woche Toben im Sudan Kämpfe
zwischen den militärm Machthabern und
paramilitärischen Kräften laut
Auswärtigem Amt hängt noch immer eine
niedrige dreistellige Zahl von deutschen
dort fest bislang ist es aber nicht
gelungen sie aus der sudanesischen
Hauptstadt kartum auszufliegen denn der
internationale Flughafen ist immer
wieder Schauplatz von Gefechten am
Mittwoch war laut Spiegel ein
evakuierungsflug mit militärtransportern
vom Typ A400M gescheitert luck
schwer bewaffnete Kämpfer der er ist
Filiz gestern im Zentrum der Hauptstadt
tattoo nach eigenen Angaben haben sie
eine Haupt Zugangsstraße zum Flughafen
unter Kontrolle gebracht der gestern
vereinbarte Waffenstillstand hielt
wieder nur ein paar Stunden seit heute
früh lag vor allem das Gebiet um den
Flughafen unter Beschuss die Menschen in
Rettung und in den Kampfgebieten des
Sudan leben seit einer Woche weitgehend
ohne Nahrungsmittel ohne Wasser und
Strom
keine Seite kann diesen Krieg gewinnen
es gibt hier nur Zerstörung Gewalt
Plünderungen
kündigte heute an die Ausreise von
ausländischen Staatsbürgern soll es
schon in den kommenden Stunden
ermöglicht werden die armeewerde die
Evakuierungen erleichtern in Berlin
berichten am Mittag Außenministerin
behrburg und Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius im Krisenstab der
Bundesregierung über die weitere
Vorgehensweise geprüft wird eine
möglichst sichere Ausreise deutscher
Staatsbürger aus dem Sudan die Situation
sei ernst so Pistorius
die Zeit drängt ein bisschen ein
bisschen mehr und deswegen ist es gut
sehr schnell noch mal den letzten letzte
Lager Update machen und vor allen Dingen
um diejenigen kümmern die sich die
größten Sorgen machen um Ihren
Aufenthalt bzw die Beendigung desselben
gestern Abend waren bereits 150
Diplomaten und Ausländer vor allem aus
Saudi-Arabien mit Fahrzeugen in die
Hafenstadt Portugal am Roten Meer
gebracht worden und von dort mit dem
Schiff weiter ins Saudi arabische Gitter
wir gehen zum Glück wahlport nach Kairo
Lück also beide Konfliktparteien sagen
eine Evakuierung zu wie belastbar sind
solche Aussagen und wie sicher wäre das
dann überhaupt
aus der Entfernung natürlich schwer zu
sagen aber es gibt sicherlich große
Zweifel wenn man sich das Kampfgeschehen
der letzten Tage anschaut zum einen war
es da so dass mehrfach Waffenruhen
vereinbart wurden Feuer Pausen und die
wurden einfach nicht eingehalten das
wirft natürlich Fragen auf ob die
Einheiten wirklich vor Ort auch das
machen was oben beschlossen wird und das
andere ist haben wir auch im Beitrag
gesehen die ganze Woche über ist dieser
Flughafen der mitten in der Stadt in
cartoon liegt schwer umkämpft auch
deshalb weil das Armee Hauptquartier am
Flughafen ist und das erleichtert also
die logistische Aufgabe für die
Sicherheitsexperten auch nicht also eine
Menge Fragezeichen gibt es da noch
vielen Dank für deine Einschätzung das
war Lück wahlport ja der Konflikt und
die Gewalt im Sudan welche Rolle spielen
dabei die Nachbarländer welche der
besten Online haben wir antworten darauf
alles noch mal für Sie jederzeit zum
Nachlesen in unserer ZDF heute App
wegen des Krieges in der Ukraine ist das
deutsch-russische Verhältnis zerrüttet
offenbar werden beidseitig auch immer
mehr Diplomaten ausgewiesen aktuell
spricht Moskau von mehr als 20 deutschen
Diplomaten die man Ausweise das ganze
als Reaktion auf Zitat
massenausweisungen von Russen die in
Deutschland diplomatisch tätig waren das
auswärtige amtssprach nicht direkt von
Ausweisungen aber vom Ziel russische
nachrichtendienstliche Präsenz in
Deutschland zu reduzieren
ein weiteres europäisches Land hat mit
Panzerlieferungen an die Ukraine
begonnen spanien hat heute die ersten
sechs Leopard Panzer verschifft vier
weitere sollen folgen in der Ukraine
selbst gehen die Kämpfe weiter das
russische Staatsfernsehen
veröffentlichte Bilder aus der Region
bachmut Moskau hat nach eigenen Angaben
drei weitere Bezirke der Stadt
eingenommen für die geplante
Gegenoffensive der Ukraine kündigte
Präsident selenski den Aufbau neuer
Militäreinheiten an
wir schauen jetzt noch mal zum
Bundesparteitag der FDP gestern da ging
es vor allem um die Wahl zum
Parteivorsitz heute standen Inhalte im
Vordergrund und da möchten die Liberalen
bei Themen wie Kernkraft oder dem
geplanten Gesetz zum Austausch älterer
Öl und Gasheizungen ihr Profil innerhalb
der Ampel schärfen mehr über die
kursbestimmung der FDP von Britta
Buchholz
in der Partei dringend auf einer anderen
Energiepolitik gerade das Thema
Heizungs-
außer Ministerium an die Öffentlichkeit
geben lassen aber diese Stück ist
einfach unerträglich für uns das
heizungsverbotsgesetz von Robert Habeck
ist
ökonomischer Unsinn der Parteichef
kritisiert öffentlich weder grüne noch
SPD doch sein Generalsekretär wird
deutlich etwa beim aus für die
Atomkraftwerke
gerade in dieser Zeit kann niemand in
Europa verstehen warum ein Land wie
Deutschland vom Instrument der
Kernenergie kein Gebrauch macht das ist
ein großer Fehler und das ist europäisch
betrachtet aber auch unsolidarisch doch
die FDP hat auch mit entschieden nun
positionieren Sie sich deutlich und
entfernen sich damit von den
Koalitionspartnern ein Konflikt den sie
nicht sehen wollen er muss sehen wir
sind drei verschiedene Parteien mit
völlig unterschiedlichen Ansätzen wir
haben uns früher darüber beschwert dass
Entscheidungen hinter verschlossenen
Türen getroffen werden jetzt müssen wir
unsere Standpunkte offen darlegen und
dann sehen damit die Menschen auch
nachvollziehen können wie wir zu
bestimmten Kompromissen kommen die
Partei will ihre Eigenständigkeit
betonen rote Linien markieren es soll um
Inhalte gehen aber es geht um mehr die
Liberalen senden hier vor allem
deutlicher Signale gegenüber ihren
Koalitionspartner grüne es dürfte noch
ungemütlicher werden vor allen Dingen
beim Thema Heizung ganz klar hier wenn
man dem Entwurf so im Bundestag nicht
zustimmen deutlich er Veränderung die
die FDP hier klar gemacht hat
der Vorsitzende der Deutschen
Bischofskonferenz Betzingen übt scharfe
Kritik am früheren Amtsinhaber Zollitsch
dieser habe in seinerzeit als Freiburger
Erzbischof entscheidende Maßnahmen zur
missbrauchsaufarbeitung nicht angewandt
er findet das verantwortungslos und sei
ratlos wie das habe passieren können so
betzing eine am Dienstag veröffentlichte
Stellungnahme bzw Gutachten über
Missbrauch im Erzbistum Freiburg wirft
solitsch Vertuschung und Täterschutz vor
er gilt als bedeutendste Auszeichnung
für Produktionen des deutschen
Fernsehens der Grimme Preis gestern
Abend wurde er verliehen traditionell in
mal und er bekam ihn schon zum sechsten
Mal jan Böhmermann für sein Magazin
Royal auch das Ensemble der netflix-show
queerei freute sich über die Ehrung
sowie Caroline Link für ihre Serie Safe
und ebenfalls eine ZDF Produktion der
Film im Feuer zwei Schwestern außerdem
ausgezeichnet das Dr AMA die
Wannseekonferenz Dominik selber
berichtet
jegliche Nähe und Mitleid erregenden weg
ich und alle beteiligten Spezialisten
sind überzeugt dass wir hier durch einen
angenehmen technischen effizienten und
vollkommen anonym Vorgang Erreichen der
von unseren Männern auf eine sehr
distanzierte Art und Weise durchgeführt
werden kann sehr beeindruckend der
grimmepreis für die Wannseekonferenz
eine Auszeichnung für eine nüchternen
bedrückenden Film so oder so ähnlich
berieten nazi-funktionäre darüber wie
der Massenmord an den Juden Europas am
besten zu organisieren sein
Konferenz ist einer unser wichtigsten
fiktionalen Produktion der letzten Jahre
weil ich glaube es ist immer wieder
wichtige Geschichte aufzuarbeiten und
gerade auch für ein junges Publikum
zugänglich zu machen auch verständlich
zu machen was in der NS-Zeit passiert
ist und umso mehr freut mich dass die
Wannsee-Konferenz hier nicht zum ersten
Mal hier prämiert wird
für ihr Lebenswerk mit dem krümelpreis
geehrt die Schauspielerin Maren
Krollmann und in der Kategorie
Unterhaltung das ZDF Magazin Royal für
seine Kombination aus Satire und
Recherche
aus Europa
[Applaus]
Qualität und Inhalte feiert
die Insel Rügen und ihre Kreidefelsen
der Königstuhl hier ist sicher der
bekannteste hunderttausende kommen
jährlich hierher zuletzt war das aber
nicht mehr ganz ungefährlich der
Aussichtspunkt wurde gesperrt seit heute
kann man den Königstuhl wieder bewundern
auf einem Skywalk der ellipsenförmig
über ihn schwebt Bernd Mosebach zeigt
uns mehr
Kaiserwetter am Königstuhl im Nordosten
der Insel der Skywalk ist eröffnet
erster Rundgang hoch oben über der
Ostsee das war so naja mal gucken
ich naschen aber es ist wirklich sehr
imposant und es ist schön wie wie sich
das einfach wirklich in die Natur in die
Natur mit einfügt wunderbare Ausblick
wunderbar Konstruktion es wackelt so ein
bisschen aber man fühlt sich trotzdem
sicher und das sind die Ausblicke die
die Besucher erwarten schwebend über den
schroffen Kreidefelsen in die Tiefe die
Stahlkonstruktion schiebt sich 87 Meter
über den Königstuhl der nun für
Touristen gesperrt ist Erosion hatte den
Kalkstein bröckeln lassen die Wege für
die Besucher wurden unsicher deshalb der
Neubau der Königstuhl ist Teil des
Nationalparks die Naturschützer können
mit dem Projekt leben
wir konzentrieren die Besucher hier den
versuchen Sie nicht selbstständig
irgendwo an die Küste zu kommen wo es
vielleicht richtig gefährlich ist und
diese Philosophie geht seit vielen
Jahren auf und wir müssen diesen Punkt
auch erlebbar halten und deswegen dieses
Bauwerk der riesige abspannmast ist
übrigens tief verankert in massiven
Gesteinsschichten der Skywalk soll so
das Versprechen der Konstrukteure
mindestens 100 Jahre halten
komm her zu ganz anderen Aussichten
nämlich die in der Fußball-Bundesliga
Norbert da kann man sagens olé und
München oh je da wirklich ein verrücktes
Spiel die Mainzer mit einer bärenstarken
zweiten Halbzeit ein hoch verdienter 3:1
haben sie gegen die Bayern heute
Nachmittag mein stürzt die Münchner noch
tiefer in die Krise erst das Bayern aus
im Pokal dann in der Champions League ja
und jetzt wackelt der dritte und letzte
angestrebte Titel der Münchner die
Meisterschaft Boris Büchler hat für uns
das Spiel im Mainzer Stadion beobachtet
Boris welche Konsequenzen kann diese
Niederlage haben
ja ganz schön viele Konsequenzen die
Bayern sind zwischen Führungsschwäche
und Titel Frust und sollte diese Saison
zum ersten Mal nach elf Jahren ohne
Titel enden dann wird das auf die Bosse
zurückfallen Thomas Tuchel wurde geholt
Julian nagelsmann wurde rausgeworfen
aber Tuchel hat nur zwei Siege geholt in
sieben Pflichtspielen das ist ziemlich
dürftig ich habe eben mit Oliver Kahn
gesprochen das Interview dann später im
Aktuellen Sportstudio komplett äh völlig
konsterniert sagte ich habe nicht
gesehen ob Bayern hier heute Meister
werden will das ist natürlich ziemlich
bitter und es droht natürlich das
nächste Bayern Beben in dieser
chaosaison danke für diese Einschätzung
Boris danke nach Mainz ja und dann
schauen wir uns jetzt die bisherigen
Ergebnisse dieses 29 Spieltags an
Mainz bedingt also die Bayern mit 3 zu 1
Hoffenheim unterliegt Köln mit 1 zu 3
Bochum kassiert eine heimklatsche gegen
Wolfsburg 1 zu 5 Hertha verliert auch
mit dem neuen Trainer Paul Dada 2:4
gegen Bremen das Abendspiel Dortmund
gegen Frankfurt an Spannung nicht zu
überbieten die Borussia könnte der
Weltführer werden und bereits gestern
Abend trennten sich Augsburg und
Stuttgart eins zu eins noch der Blick
auf die Tabelle die Bayern mit zwei
Punkten Vorsprung auf Dortmund der BVB
kann also durch einen Sieg im Abendspiel
gegen die Eintracht an München vorbei
ziehen Union Dritter Leipzig vierter
Freiburg Fünfter und meins durch den
Sieg jetzt sechster und damit auf einem
Europapokalplatz die zweite
Tabellenhälfte beginnt mit Gladbach und
am Tabellen Ende erstmal alles
unverändert Bochum Stuttgart Schalke und
schlosslicht Hertha
das Abendspiel Dortmund gegen Frankfurt
ausführlich bei uns zu sehen ebenso
natürlich alles rund um die Bayern
Niederlage in Mainz im Aktuellen
Sportstudio um
23:30 Uhr
zu den Halbfinal Hinspielen in der
Fußball Champions League der Frauen
morgen müssen die wölfinen nach London
zu as ne und schon hatte spielte der
andere englische Halbfinalist Chelsea
gegen Barcelona ja und verlor zu Hause
knapp mit Nutzer eins Barca mit guten
Chancen auf den dritten Finale Einzug in
Folge
erst drei Minuten gespielt und schon
jubelt der Gasthaus Barcelona an der
Londoner Stampfer Bridge Caroline Graham
Hansen die Norwegerin bleibt unbehelligt
von der Chelsea Abwehr die Quittung ein
frühes Gegentor im Halbfinale der beiden
Finalistinnen von 2021 Chelsea mit
diesem zügigen Angriff der Torjubel
allerdings verfrüht abseits der Treffer
von Guru reiten auch einer Norwegerin
erzählt nicht der deutschen
Nationalspielerin Ann-Kathrin Berger ist
es zu verdanken dass es nur beim 01
bleibt Rolf VÖs Schuss pariert sie
prächtig mehr als 25.000 Zuschauer
Heimspiel Rekord für Chelsea in der
Champions League und die Zahl der
Barca-Fans dürfte beim Rückspiel
nächsten Donnerstag noch deutlich
anwachsen
auf jeden Fall das war sofort vielen
Dank aber gerne morgen ist es
unbeständig nicht mehr so warm wie heute
mehr im Wetter gleich von Christa Orben
um 23:15 Uhr ist heute journal mit
Marietta Slomka das war die heute 19 am
Samstag danke fürs zuschauen schönen
Abend bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend bei uns war das heute der
bisher wärmste Tag des Jahres mit bis 24
Grad ungewöhnlich ist es allerdings
welche Hitze sich schon wieder im Süden
Spaniens anbahnt schon morgen erreichen
wir dort 30 Grad im Laufe der nächsten
Woche ist das mit Luft aus Nordafrika
rekordverdächtig heiß hier um 35 Grad
bei uns und über Mitteleuropa allerdings
passiert genau das Gegenteil ein
Kaltlufteinbruch aus Nordwest heute
Nacht allerdings erstmal noch nicht die
ist recht mild 7 Grad stellenweise im
Westen unter den Regen Wolken bleibt es
bei 12 Grad diese Regenwolken gehören zu
einer Kaltfront die zunächst einmal mit
kurzem Gewittern auch noch hier über der
Mitte von Nord nach Süd über dem Land
liegt und sich bis zum nachtausgang dann
in die Osthälfte verlagert und so haben
wir morgen Vormittag im Osten noch den
Regen ansonsten wechseln sich
Quellwolken mit sonnigen Abschnitten ab
es gibt aber schon einzelne Schauer und
auch kurze Gewitter im Nordwesten
nachmittags zieht der Regen dann aus
Osten ab hier wird es freundlicher im
Westen und auch über den Bergland bilden
sich aber verstärkt Schauer und vor
allem gegen Abend kommen dann aus
Südwesten und Westen auch noch mal
stärkere Gewitter und stärkere Regen
rein bei einem spürbaren südlichen Wind
das ganze bei nicht mehr ganz so milden
Temperaturen wie heute 20 Grad mit
sonnenunterstützung am Rhein 15 16 an
der See und in der neuen Woche sinken
die Temperaturen dann ab auf nur noch 6
bis 11 Grad am Dienstag unter Mittwoch
das war es von uns tschüss